[Applause]
this is the hell that's lizzy shanks and
it's a hell that never falls silent
look to the right of that huge black
plume of smoke
that fresh puff is yet another shell
exploding on a horizon already foggy
with destruction
the city's being surrounded by russian
troops bit by bloody bit this bridge
over the railway was the main route in
the russian circles nearly complete
the attackers are using brute force to
sledgehammer their way in from several
directions
we drove in as they mounted their latest
ferocious onslaught on the city's oil
refinery the second largest in ukraine i
don't think we should hang around here
too
it felt akin to riding into some sort of
armageddon
lissa shanks is the last remaining
stronghold in the lehansk region of the
donbass losing this city will be a
monumental loss
part of the plant is on fire many other
areas have been hit badly there are
shells coming in every few minutes
but the ukrainians are fighting the
fight of their lives
and they've been battling over this
pocket of the donbass for months
we're with the soldiers of the 24th
brigade sworn to secrecy about their
exact location inside the plant
they're on the move to another fighting
position the russian troops are 500
meters away and they've come under
savage attack here but they're bitterly
disappointed about losing their twin
city of sever donetsk it's made their
defense of lizzie shanks all the more
important
they don't want to give up an inch of
territory but they follow their orders
yes it was the right decision he says
better to save lives
but every bit swallowed up by the
russians hurts and their enemies are
making slow but steady progress
we are going out but some other units
will stay the battalion commander tells
us he goes on to insist no one's leaving
lizzy shanks we just want to regroup in
a better position he says
but the ukrainian hold on this city
looks very tenuous right now
but even as they hastily relocated there
was an air of this being the final
battle for lizzie shanks
they've held the russians at bay for
weeks now forcing some heavy losses on
them and buying time to build up
defenses in donetsk the second half of
the donbass where the russians will move
to next
but they're coming under intense
pressure on the donbass battlefield and
even relocating involves casualties as
they're forced to run the gauntlet of
fresh shelling
amid the mayhem of this grim fighting
the explosions and hurry to shift has
led to a head-on crash
the injured are having to be rapidly
extracted and treated whilst the heavy
smog offers them some slight cover
those who make it out alive from the
line of fire are utterly exhausted and
high on relief and almost surprised
they're still in one piece
but there's a growing exasperation at
what they see as the delay in sending
long-range artillery and better weapons
for them to somehow finish this fighting
it would be much better if you send us
some new weapons are you struggling with
the stuff you've got at the moment well
can't say that we're struggling but it
would be much better you know
they take high losses we need to retreat
but in the end again they will
go forward again we will beat them will
with artillery
they will again
they have a
great amount of losses so what what's
your message to nato and the rest of
europe
the foot soldiers aren't mincing their
words anymore
but there's a determination and courage
here that far outstrips the diminishing
odds of victory even as they race to a
front to replace colleagues and where
they're vastly outnumbered and
outflanked
they're still showing key spines
19 year old eugene has a face etched
with the grime of war and seeing friends
die in several donetsk he spent four
months sleeping and battling inside this
armored vehicle
he's old enough to fight and nearly die
but young enough to question withdrawing
from
[Music]
foreign
but the city is being changed beyond
recognition with every major landmark in
the center damaged or destroyed
it's a mass of debris and destruction
the city's authorities and police say
already about three quarters of the area
is devastated
there are several thousand residents
still here
where the rumble of deadly weaponry is
now part of their daily routine and
increased with a savage intensity over
the past few days
hear that whistle and that crunch we
know that they're coming from the south
of the city where there's a column
of russian armory which is trying to
encircle the city and they keep landing
minute every two minutes
we saw no sign of any russian troops
inside lizzy shanks despite russian
claims but we did spot the ukrainians
driving back captured russian armor
their blue and yellow flag flying above
it now
but even amid this small triumph there
are shells coming in
forcing the curious nearby residents to
take cover again
the ukrainians are inflicting some
serious casualties on their russian
enemies but it's still not enough to
hold them back
civilians led us to the body of a
russian soldier which they say was
dumped out of the captured personnel
carrier
he'd obviously been badly hurt and had a
tourniquet around his leg
the discarded russian army uniforms were
laid out for the residents to see
while the police documented all the
evidence for any future investigation
including exactly how he died and what
he was doing
with no electricity there's no operating
morgue but his dna will be taken to try
to identify him
volunteers have the awful task of
bagging the corpse
[Applause]
then the body is loaded into one of the
few operating vehicles in the city a
larder so small one of the volunteers
has to sit cradling the dead russian
soldier on his lap whilst his colleagues
finish up gathering his personal items
both life and death in lizzy shanks is
utterly surreal
the russians deny they're targeting
civilians but plenty of homes are being
hit in the fight to seize this city
a few meters away from the flames in
this building we find iho a pensioner
who's struggling to accept his flats
been bombed overnight both floors above
his are burned right through
are you still are you still staying in
there
good
with smoking flats all around him his
determined sprinkling of water to bring
down the heat doesn't seem nearly enough
to stop the fire's march
yet the pain of giving up what's his is
too much and it's this refusal to give
in that we've seen repeated over and
over again in this country
alex crawford sky news in lissy shanks
in the donbass eastern ukraine